hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the try not to laugh
challenge where I find the absolute
worst videos on the internet and somehow
laugh to him because I have no sense of
humor also before we get started the
tour tickets are on sale now if you go
to markiplier com or click the link in
the description below it's also
markiplier comm you will see where we
are touring what cities we're going to
and how you can get tickets right now so
anyway enough of that in a pandering
enough self-promotion make me laugh I
dare you I double dog dare you just do
it already
[Music]
that gorilla had some moves
don't do this to me not funny no don't
do this not again
don't do this I've been through this
before with the same dog
okay I don't know all right it's fine
you you almost got me I was prepared but
I was ready for a new something was
coming the new sim was come what exactly
did you see them take they was working
on the tires that's all that was took
don't know why that almost
who make it the same face no not funny I
don't know why I don't know why I don't
I was I don't know why I lowered my
shields for a second there I don't know
why but there wasn't a laugh I'm not
funny you can make me laugh no tell me
that was a LARP session
where you going with this
[Music]
euphoria Calvin Klein
[Music]
nope not laughs that was an exhalation
of breath not laughs everybody knows
that kazoo be kazoos are some of the
loudest in the world but now we have the
loudest kazoo you can get the kazoo
because oboe
[Music]
all right you've overstayed your welcome
your barber played rain banjo kazooie
this is it
this is what matters the experience of a
product how will it make someone feel
[Music]
will it make life better
[Music]
does it deserve to exist nope no I don't
know why I found that funny either
I didn't that's the point of the video
[Music]
that was adorable
whoever made that is goddamn you
[Music]
was called CrossFit Cindy oh no no no no
no no no no no no no samuel l.jackson
like enemy yes I do
hint I - foolish samurai warrior
wielding a shape-shifting master of
Darkness wielding a magic sword wielding
a foolish samurai warrior wielding a
magic sword shut the hell up don't you
don't do that don't do that the money in
the bag
[Music]
Glade plugins scented oil fans all Roger
don't even knowing it's the only
freshener to use the continuous built-in
fans
unlike some fresheners throughout your
whole plug-in scented oil fan from Glade
the doer [ __ ] magic of fragrant
so painful to keep those spasms in my
chest whatever you're about to do don't
do it you know yeah video I told you not
to do that
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] all right well I lost wash the
toilet after the cutoff [ __ ] well it was
[ __ ] one who's taking your boat for a
walk that wasn't even fine I got doing
the challenge anymore of a god damn
funny
[Laughter]
oh Jesus Christ Jesus I love that me all
right I've only got do one more all
right
oh okay all right so that's it for the
try not to laugh challenge god this is a
point I'm legitimately crying alright
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought in the
comments below if you want to see more
of this let me know down there as well
and remember the tour tickets are on
sale go - markiplier comm or look in the
link in the description below that also
goes to markiplier comm and see if I
made your city so thanks again everybody
for watching and also as always I will
see you in the next I will see you in
the next video bye bye